this is technically your third right is
this your third that's okay yeah this is
the what is what is it with you guys you
just keep working you know it's not us
it's the universe it wants us the
universe is shipping us a want sausage
not your stalking her it's chemistry
yeah what I mean you're telling me you
know
[Applause]
so it's uh it you clearly you to work so
well together
you are the newcomer to the show you're
also the only Brit in Neptune you're the
only Brit how does that feel to you did
was there ever any thought that maybe
you would go with an American actor
actually I think at the first table read
I did an American accent and then I got
a note shortly after that was like no.6
British so I don't know if that was like
she just just be you but I do think part
of it is that Rob and Kristen and and
everyone involved sort of like the
beauty of the show is that they want
people to bring themselves to the
character and I think all of the
characters are a little bit of us and I
think having the accent made it made it
that much more mean what's that you know
I can't my British accent is very
offensive to British people you know
that's why hello Guv'nor
you know sweep your chimney or will or
will you know it yeah you know bangers
and mash family knows they travel
annoyed for me first look at that you're
happy now you're happy yeah I'm happy
I'm so sorry % you have said that you
will play this character Veronica into
your 80s do not I'll play Veronica Mars
until everyone in Neptune is dead that's
fancy so and you'll be the last one
there and then you'll realize it was all
me I twist stick with it